I'm 22 years old I'm six foot two and
I'm in shape but I've run into this
problem where I can't really get women
who are not overweight to even look my
way it's because your smv is not high
enough dude where do you live in
Nebraska Nebraska that's part of your
problem if you're not going to get a lot
of hot looking chicks living in Nebraska
should you practice game on women that
you aren't really attracted to practice
no I've I wouldn't recommend that get to
the point of competing is what I'm
getting at do you want hotter women
you're attracted to hotter women
obviously there's nothing wrong with
that but for you to get those chicks you
need to be better so compete be better
or keep your standards low and just you
know shoot the fish in the barrel if
that's all you want to deal with what
kind of car do you drive Toyota Camry
[ __ ] boring dude you got to be
captivating with women right like you
know you can't just put on the two can
just rock back and forth and think you
know I'm tall I got this just lean into
the ones that you want man and if
they're not responding to you then that
means you got some work to do